it's not our business
changed the Russian government and
anybody who thinks it's a good idea to
do regime change in Russia which has
more nuclear weapons than we do
um is I think irresponsible and you know
Vladimir Putin himself has said you know
we will not live in a world without
Russia and it was clear when he said
that that he was talking about himself
and I and he has his hand on a button
that could bring you know Armageddon to
the entire planet so why are we messing
with this it's not our job to change
that regime and and we should be making
Fair friends with the Russians we
shouldn't be treating him as an anime
now we've pushed them into the camp with
China
that's not a good thing for our country
and by the way
you know what we're doing now does not
appear to be weakening Putin at all
the following is a conversation with
Robert F Kennedy Jr candidate for the
president of the United States running
as a Democrat Robert is an activist
lawyer and author who has challenged
some of the world's most powerful
corporations seeking to hold them
accountable for the harm they may cause
I love science and engineering these two
Pursuits are to me the most beautiful
and Powerful in the history of human
civilization science is our journey our
fight for uncovering the laws of nature
and leveraging them to understand the
universe and to lessen the amount of
suffering in the world
some of the greatest human beings I've
ever met including most of my good
friends are scientists and Engineers
again I love science
but science cannot flourish without
epistemic humility without debate both
in the pages of academic journals and in
the Public Square in good faith
long-form conversations agree or
disagree I believe Robert's voice should
be part of the debate to call him a
conspiracy theorist and arrogantly
dismiss everything he says without
addressing it diminishes The public's
trust in the scientific process
at the same time dogmatic skepticism of
all scientific output on controversial
topics like the pandemic is equally if
not more dishonest and destructive
I recommend that people read and listen
to Robert F Kennedy Jr his arguments and
his ideas
but I also recommend as I say in this
conversation that people read and listen
to Vincent record yellow from this week
in virology Dan Wilson from debunk the
funk and the Twitter and books of Paul
offit Eric tople and others who are
outspoken in their disagreement with
Robert
it is disagreement not Conformity that
bends the long Arc of humanity toward
truth and wisdom
in this process of this agreement
everybody has a lesson to teach you but
we must have the humility to hear it and
to learn from it
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Robert F Kennedy Jr
it's the fourth of July Independence Day
so simple question simple big question
what do you love about this country the
United States of America I would say
well there are so many things that I
love about the country on uh
you know the Landscapes and the
waterways and the people Etc but on the
kind of a you know the higher level you
know people argue about whether we're an
exemplary Nation
and the that term has been given a bad
name particularly by the neocons the
actions the neocons in in recent decades
who
have turned that uh that phrase into
kind of a justification
for forcing people to adopt American
systems or values at the barrel of a gun
but my father and Uncle used it in a
very different way and they were very
proud of it I grew up very proud of this
country because we were the exemplary
nation in in uh in the sense that we
were an example of
democracy all over the world when we uh
when we first launched our democracy in
we were the only democracy on Earth and
by the Civil War by 1865 there were six
democracies
today there's probably 190.
and all of them in one way or another
are modeled on on the American
experience and it's kind of
extraordinary because
or if our our first contact with uh our
first serious and contact
uh with the European culture and
continent was in 1608
I want John went through came over with
his Puritans and the Sloop Arbella and
Winthrop gave this famous speech where
he said this is going to be a city on a
hill this is going to be an example for
you know all the other nations in the
world and he he warned his fellow
Puritans they were you know sitting at
the this great expanse of land he said
we can't
um be we can't uh uh be seduced by
the the war of real estate or by the
carnal opportunities of this land we
have to take this country as a gift from
God and then turn it into a uh an
example for the rest of the world of of
God's love of God's Will and uh and
wisdom and the and then you know to 200
years later 250 years later
they are a different generation they're
mainly Dias or people who
um had a a belief in God but not uh so
much
a love of particularly religious
cosmologies you know the framers the
Constitution
um believe that we were creating
something that would be replicated
around the world and that it was an
example it was in democracy
there would be this kind of wisdom from
the collective you know that and the
word wisdom means the knowledge of God's
will
and that somehow God would speak through
the collective in a way that um
that he or she could not speak through
you know through totalitarian regimes
and um you know I think that that's
something that even though uh
Winthrop was a white man and a
Protestant that every immigrant group
who came after them I kind of adopted
that belief and I know my family when
you know our my family came up all of my
grandparents came over in 1848 during
the Potato Famine
and they saw this country as unique in
history as something that
you know that was uh
that was part of kind of a broader
spiritual Mission and so I I'd say that
from a thirty thousand foot level that
uh you know that's I grew up so proud of
this country and believing that it was
the greatest country in the world and
for those reasons well I immigrated to
this country and one of the things that
really embodies America to me is the
ideal of Freedom Hunter Thompson said
freedom is something that dies unless
it's used what does freedom mean to you
to me Freedom does not mean you know
chaos
and it does not mean Anarchy it means
that it it it has to be accompanied by
restraint if it's going to
uh live up to its promise
um in the self first right what it means
the capacity for human beings to
um to exercise and to
fulfill their uh their creative Energies
unrestrained as much as possible by
government so this point the hunter
estas has made is dies unless it's used
I agree with that yeah I do agree with
that and I think he'd
he was not unique in saying that you
know Thomas Jefferson said that the tree
of Liberty has to be had to be watered
with the blood of each generation and
what he meant by that is that it's it's
uh you can't live off we can't live off
The Laurels of the American Revolution
that you know we had a group we had a
generation where between 25 000 and 70
000 Americans died they gave their lives
they gave their livelihoods they gave
their
status they gave their property and they
put it all on the line to give us our
Bill of Rights and that but those Bill
rights the moment that we signed them
there were forces within our society
um that began trying to chip away at
them and that you know what happens in
every generation and it is the
obligation of every generation
to safeguard and protect those freedoms
the blood of each generation you
mentioned your interests your admiration
of Albert Camus of stoicism perhaps your
interest in existentialism
Camus said
I believe in myth of Sisyphus the only
way to deal with an unfree world is to
become so absolutely free that your very
existence is an act of rebellion what do
you think he means by that I suppose the
way that kamu
view the world
um and the way that the stoics did and a
lot of the existentialists was that it
was uh that it was so absurd and that
the uh the the problems and the tasks
that were given just to live a life are
so insurmountable
that the only way that we can kind of um
get back the gods for giving us this you
know this uh this uh impossible task of
of living life
was to embrace it and to enjoy it and to
do our our best at it I mean to me I
you know I read camo and then
particularly in the myth of Sisyphus as
a
um as kind of as a parable that uh and
it's the same lesson that I think he he
writes about in the plague
where we're all given these
insurmountable tasks in our lives but
um that uh by doing our duty by being of
service to others
we can bring meaning to a meaningless
chaos and we can bring order to the
universe and
you know Sisyphus was uh was kind of the
iconic hero of the stoics
and he was a man because he did uh
because he did something good he
delivered a gift to humanity
he angered the gods and they condemned
him to put a rock up the hill every day
and then it would roll down when he got
to the top it would roll down and he'd
spend the night going back down the hill
to collect it and then rolling it back
back up the hill again
and the task was observed it was
insurmountable he could never win
but the last line of that book is one of
the great lines which is uh which is
something to the extent that you know I
can picture Earth says smiling because
Camus belief was that even though he um
his task was insurmountable that he was
a happy man
and he was a happy man because he put
his shoulder to the stone
he took his duty he embraced the tasks
and the you know and the absurdity of
life and he pushed the stone up the hill
and that if we do that and if you know
we find ways of being service to others
that is you know the ultimate
that's the key to the lock that's the
solution to the puzzle each individual
person in that way can rebel against
absurdity by discovering meaning to this
whole messy thing and we can bring
meaning not only to our own lives but
we can bring meaning to the universe as
well we can bring some kind of order to
life
um
uh you know that those the Embrace of
those tasks and the and the commitment
to service
resonates out from us to the rest of
humanity in some in some way
so you mentioned the plague by Camus
there's a lot of different ways to read
that book but one of them especially
given How It Was Written is that the
plague symbolizes uh Nazi Germany
and the Hitler regime what do you learn
about human nature
from a figure like Adolf Hitler that
he's able to
uh Captivate the minds of millions rise
to power and take on pull in the whole
world into a global war
I was born nine years after the end of
World War II
and I grew up in a generation that was
big you know with my parents who were
fixated on that
um on you know what happened at my
father
at that time the you know the kind of
the resolution in the minds of most
Americans and I think people around the
world
is that there was there had been
something wrong with the German people
that you know the Germans had been
particularly susceptible to this kind of
a demagoguery and to following a
powerful leader and um and his
industrializing cruelty and and and uh
and murder
and my father always differed with that
and my father said this is not a German
problem
this could happen to all of us we're all
just inches away from barbarity and the
thing that keeps us safe in this country
are the institutions of our democracy
our constitution is it's not our nature
you know our nature
has to
um
has to be restrained and it and that
comes through self-restraint but it also
you know the beauty of our country is
that we develop we devise these
institutions that are designed to allow
us to flourish
but at the same time on not to give us
enough freedom to flourish but also
create enough order to keep us from
collapsing into barbarity so
um you know one of the other things that
my father
talked about from when I was little you
know he would ask us this question
if you if you were the family
and Anne Frank came to your door and
asked you to hide her would you be one
of the people who hit her at risked your
own life or would you be one of the
people who turned her in
and of course we would all say of course
we would hide Anne Frank and take the
risk
um but you know that's been something uh
kind of a lesson a challenge that has
been uh that has always been near the
Forefront of my mind that if a
totalitarian system ever
occurs in the United States which my
father thought was quite possible he he
was conscious about how fragile
democracy actually is
um that would I be one of the ones who
would resist the totalitarianism or
would I be one of the people who
went along with it would I be one of the
people who was at the train station and
you know Krakow or uh or
um or you know even Berlin and saw
people
being shipped off to camps and just put
my head down and pretend I didn't see it
because talking about it would be
destructive to my career maybe my
freedom and even my life
um so you know that has been a challenge
that my father gave to me and all of my
brothers and sisters and
it's something that I I've never
forgotten a lot of us would like to
believe we would uh resist in that
situation but the reality is most of us
wouldn't and that's a good thing to
think about
that uh human nature is such that we're
selfish even when there's an atrocity
going on all around us and we also you
know we have the capacity to deceive
ourselves
and all of us tend to kind of Judge
ourselves by our intentions and our
actions
what have you learned about life from
your father Robert F Kennedy first of
all I'll say this about my uncle because
you know I'm going to apply that
question to my uncle and my father my
uncle was asked when he first met Jackie
Bouvier who later became Jackie Kennedy
she was a reporter for a newspaper and
she was doing she she had a kind of
column where she'd do these these kind
of um
pithy interviews uh with with both
famous people and Men industry in
interviews
and she was interviewing him and she
asked them
um
what she thought what he believed his
best quality was is his strongest virtue
and she thought that he would say
courage because
he had been a war hero he had he was the
only uh president who and this one he
was Senator by the way
who received the purple heart and you
know he had a very kind of famous story
of him as a hero in World War II and
then he had come home and he'd written a
book on car on moral courage among
American politicians and one Pulitzer
Prize
that book profiles and courage and um
which was a series of incidents where
um American political leaders made
decisions to to embrace principle even
though their careers were at stake and
in most cases were destroyed by their
choice
she thought he was going to say courage
but he didn't he said curiosity
and
um I think you know looking back at his
life that the best that that was true
and that was the quality that allowed
him
to put himself in the shoes of his
adversaries and he always said that if
you if the only way that we're going to
have peace is if we're able to put
ourselves in the shoes or adversaries
understand their behavior and their
contact not context
and that's why he was able to
um you know during the uh he was able to
resist the intelligence apparatus in the
military
during the Bay of Pigs when they said
you've got to send in the Essex the
aircraft carrier and he said no even
though he'd only been in two months in
office he was able to stand up to them
because
of because he was able to put himself in
the shoes of both Castro and Khrushchev
and understand there's got to be another
solution to this and then during the
Cuban Missile Crisis
he was able to do it when the narrative
was okay Khrushchev acted
in a way as an aggressor to put missiles
in our hemisphere how dare he do that
and Jack and my father were able to say
well wait a minute he's doing that
because we put missiles in turkey and
Italy that were right on you know the
Turkish ones right on the Russian border
and they then made a secret deal with
dobrandon with ambassador to Brennan and
you know with Khrushchev
um to uh to remove the missiles in in
Turkey if he moved the Jupiter missiles
from Turkey if I'm
so long as Khrushchev removed them from
from Cuba every there were 13 men on the
exact on the end what they call the ncon
committee
which was the group of people who were
deciding you know what the action was
what what they were going to do to end
the Cuban muscle crisis and virtually
and of those men 11 of them wanted to
invade and wanted to bomb and invade
and it was Jack and then later on my my
father and and Bob McNamara who are the
only people who were with him
but because he was able to see the world
from khrushchev's point of view of you
he believed that there was another
solution and then he also had the moral
courage so
um my father you know to get back to
your question
famously is that that moral courage is
the most important quality and it's more
it's more rare and courage on the
football field or courage in battle than
physical courage it's much more
difficult to come by but it's the most
important quality in a human being and
you think that kind of empathy that you
referred to that requires moral courage
it certainly
requires moral courage to
to act on it you know and particularly
you know in
you know any time that a nation is at
War there is kind of a momentum or an
inertia that says okay let's not look at
this from the other person's point of
view
and um that's the time we really need to
do that well if you can apply that
style of empathy style of curiosity to
the current war in Ukraine
what is your understanding of why Russia
invaded Ukraine in February 2022
Vladimir Putin could have avoided the
war in the Ukraine well his invasion was
illegal it was unnecessary and it was
brutal
um but
I think it's important for us
to move Beyond these kind of comic book
depictions of a uh you know of this
insane uh avaricious
Russian leader who wants to you know
restore the Soviet Empire and that
that's why and it was I and who made an
unfoged unprovoked
um
invasion of the Ukraine he was provoked
and we were provoking them and we were
provoking him for for since 1997.
and it's not just me that's saying that
I mean when when and before right before
Putin never came in
we were provoking Russia Russians in
this way unnecessarily
and to go back that time in 1992 when
the Russians moved out when the Soviet
Union was collapsing
the Russians moved out of East Germany
and they did that which was a huge
concession and they had 400 000 troops
in East Germany at that time and they
were facing NATO troops on the other
side of the wall
a Gorbachev made this huge concession
where he said to George Bush
I'm going to move all of our troops out
and you can then reunify Germany under
NATO which was a hostile Army to the to
the South it was created to you know uh
with hostile intent with the Soviet
Union
and he said you can take Germany but I
want your promise that you will not move
NATO to the East and James Baker who was
the Secretary of State famously said
I will not move NATO we will not move
Nato one inch to the east so then five
years later in 1997 it's a big new
Brzezinski who was kind of the father of
the neocons
who's a Democrat that time served in the
in the uh Carter Administration
he said he published a paper a blueprint
for moving NATO right up to the Russian
border a thousand miles to the east
and and taking over 14 Nations
and at that time George Cannon who was
the kind of the deity of American
diplomats he was probably arguably
arguably the most important Diplomat in
American history
he was the architect of the containment
policy during World War II
and he said this is insane and it's
unnecessary and if you do this it's
going to provoke the Soviet uh I mean
the Russians of violent response and we
should be making friends with the
Russians they lost the Cold War
we should be treating them the way that
we treated the our adversaries after
World War II like with a Marshall plan
to try to help them incorporate into
Europe and to be part of the the
Brotherhood of you know of man and of
Western Nations we shouldn't continue to
be treating him as an enemy and
particularly surrounding them at their
borders
William Perry who was then the Secretary
of State of uh defense under Bill
Clinton threatened to resign he was so
upset by this plan to move NATO to the
ease
and William Burns who is then the U.S
ambassador of the Soviet Union who's now
at this moment the head of the CIA said
at the time the same thing
if you do this it is going to provoke
the Russians toward a military response
and the we we moved it we moved all
around Russia we moved to 14 Nations a
thousand miles to the East and we put
eight dismissal systems
and two nations in Romania and Poland so
we did what you know what the Russians
had done to us in 1962 that ever vote
would have provoked an invasion of Cuba
we put those missile systems back there
and then we walk away unilaterally walk
away from the two uh nuclear missile
treaties the intermediate nuclear
missile treaties that we had with us
with Russia
and when neither of us would put on
those missile systems on the borders
we walk away from that and we put Aegis
missile systems which are nuclear
capable they can carry the Tomahawk
missile switch of nuclear warheads so
the last uh country that they didn't
take was the Ukraine and the Russians
said and in effect Bill Perry said this
or William Byrne said it so now the head
of the CIA
it is a red line if we go into if we
bring NATO into Ukraine that is a red
line for the Russians they cannot live
with it they cannot live with it Russia
has been invaded
three times through the Ukraine
the last time it was invaded we killed
or the Germans killed one out of every
seven Russians they destroyed my uncle
described what happened to Russia
um in his famous American University
speech in in uh in 1963
60 years ago this month
or he's or last month 60 years ago in
June June 10th 1963. he told that speech
was telling American people put yourself
in the choose the Russians
we need to do that if we're gonna if
we're gonna make peace
and he said all of us have been taught
you know that we won the war but we
didn't win the war the Russians if
anybody won the war against Hitler was
the Russians
their country was destroyed they they
all of their cities and he said imagine
if all of the Cities
on the east coast of Chicago were
reduced to rubble and all of the fields
Burns all the force Burns that's what
happened to Russia that's what they gave
so that we could get rid of Adolf Hitler
and he had them put themselves in their
position and you know today there's none
of that happening we have refused
repeatedly to uh to talk to the Russians
we've broken up there's two treaties the
Minsk agreements which the Russians were
willing to sign and they said we will
stay out the Russians didn't want the
Ukraine they showed that
when they when the Don BOS region voted
90 to 10
to leave and go to Russia Putin said no
we want Ukraine to stay intact but we
want you to sign a Memphis Accords to to
you know they the Russians were were
very worried because of the U.S
involvement in the coup in Ukraine in
2014.
and then the oppression and the and the
you know and the killing of 14 000
ethnic Russians and Russia hasn't had
the same reason the same way that if
Mexico
would Aegis missile systems from China
or Russia on our border and then killed
000 expats American we would go in there
oh he does have a national security
interest in the Ukraine he has an
interest in protecting the
russian-speaking people of the Ukraine
yeah I think Russians and
the Minsk accordions at it it left
Ukraine as part of Russia and left him
as a semi-autonomous region that could
continue to use their own language which
is essentially banned by the coup by the
government we put in in 2014.
um and uh and we wouldn't we we
sabotaged that agreement and and we now
know in April of 2022
zielinski and uh Putin had Inked a deal
already to another peace agreement and
that the United States sent Boris
Johnson the neocons in the White House
and Boris Johnson over to the Ukraine to
sabotage that agreement so
what do I think I think this is a proxy
war I think this is a you know this is a
war that the neoconsi and the White
House wanted they've said for two
decades they wanted this war
and that they wanted to use Ukraine as a
pawn in a proxy war between uh United
States and Russia the same as we used
Afghanistan
and in fact they say it this is the
model let's use the Afghanistan model
that was set again and again and to to
get the Russians to overextend their
troops and then fight them using local
uh Fighters and U.S weapons
and when President Biden was asked why
are we in the Ukraine he was honest he
says to depose Vladimir Putin regime
change for Vladimir Putin and when his
defense secretary Lloyd Austin in April
2022 was asked you know why are we there
he said to degrade the Russians capacity
to fight anywhere to exhaust the Russian
army and degrade its capacity to fight
elsewhere in the world
that's not a humanitarian Mission that's
not what we were told we were we were
told this was an unprovoked invasion
but
and that we're there to bring a
humanitarian relief to the ukrainians
but that is the opposite that is a war
of attrition that is designed to chew up
turn this little nation into an abattoir
of death for the flower of Ukrainian
youth in order to advance a geopolitical
ambition of certain people within the
White House and uh you know I think
that's wrong
we should be talking to the Russians the
way that you know Nixon talked to
prashnav
the way that bush talked to Gorbachev
the way that my uncle talked to
Khrushchev we need to be talking with
the Russians we should and and and
negotiating and we need to be looking
about how do we end this and preserve
peace in Europe would you as president
sit down and have a conversation with
Vladimir Putin and Vladimir zolensky
separately and together to negotiate
peace absolutely
what about Vladimir Putin
he's been in power since 2000.
so as the old adage goes power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
uh do you think he is
been corrupted by being in power for so
long if you think of the male if you
look at his mind listen I don't know
exactly
um I can't say because I just I don't
know enough about him or about you know
like my the evidence that I've seen
is that he is homicidal he kills his
enemies or poisons them
and you know the reaction I've seen to
that to hit those accusations from him
have not been to deny that but to kind
of laugh it off
I think he's a dangerous man and that of
course you know
um there's probably corruption in his
regime but having said that
it's not our business
to change the Russian government and
anybody who thinks it's a good idea to
do regime change in Russia which has
more nuclear weapons than we do
um is I think irresponsible and you know
Vladimir Putin himself has said you know
we will not live in a world without
Russia and it was clear when he said
that that he was talking about himself
and uh and he has his hand on a button
that could bring you know Armageddon to
the entire planet so why are we messing
with this it's not our job to change
that regime and and we should be making
friends with the Russians we shouldn't
be treating him as an enemy now we've
pushed him into the camp with China
that's not a good thing for our country
and by the way
you know what we're doing now does not
appear to be weakening Putin at all
Putin now you know if you believe the
the polls that are coming out of
Russia
they show him you know the most recent
polls that I've seen
um show him with that 89 popularity that
people in Russia support the war in
Ukraine
and that and they supported him as an
individual
so um and I understand there's problems
with polling and you know you don't know
what to believe but but the polls
consistently show that and
um and I you know it's not America's
business to be the policeman of the
world and to be changing regimes in the
world that's illegal or not we shouldn't
be breaking International laws
you know we should actually be looking
for ways
to improve relationships with Russia not
to you know not to destroy Russia not to
destroy and not to choose its leadership
for them that's up to the Russian people
not us so step one is to sit down and
empathize with the leaders of both
Nations to understand their history
their concerns their hopes
just to open the door for conversation
so they're not back to the corner and I
think the U.S can play
a really important role and a U.S
president can play a really important
role by reassuring the Russians that
we're not going to consider them an
enemy anymore that we want to be friends
and it doesn't mean that you have to let
down your guard completely the way that
you do it which was the way President
Kennedy did it is you do it one step at
a time you take baby steps we do a
unilateral move
reduce or you know our our hostility and
aggression and see if the Russians
reciprocate and um and that's the way
that we should be doing it and you know
we should be easing our way
into a positive relationship with Russia
we have a lot in common with Russia and
we should be friends with Russia and
with the Russian people I mean you know
apparently there's been 350 000
ukrainians
who have died at least in this war and
uh and there's probably been uh 60 or 80
000 Russians and that should not give us
any Joy it should not give us any you
know I saw
Lindsey Graham on TV saying you know
anything we can something to the extent
that anything we can do to kill Russians
is a good use of our money that it is
not you know those are those are
somebody's children they're you know we
should have compassion for them this war
is an unnecessary War we should settle
it through negotiation through diplomacy
through statecraft
and not through weapons do you think
this war can come to an end purely
through military
operations no I mean I don't think
there's any way in the world that the
ukrainians can beat the Russians I don't
think there's any appetite in Europe I
think Europe is now you know uh in
having severe problems in Germany Italy
France you're seeing these riots there's
internal problems in those countries
there is no appetite in
um in uh in Europe for sending men to
die in Ukraine and the ukrainians do not
have anybody left the ukrainians are
using press gangs too uh to you know to
fill the ranks of their armies men
military age men
are trying as hard as they can to get
out of the Ukraine right now to avoid
going to the front the front you know
the Russians apparently have been
killing ukrainians in a seven to one
ratio
my son fought over there and he told me
it's not you know artillery he had
um he had fire fights with the Russians
mainly at night but he said most of the
battles were artillery wars during the
day and that the Russians now out uh
outgun the NATO forces ten to one in
artillery
oh they're killing at a horrendous rate
now you know my interpretation of what's
happened so far is that the
Putin actually went in early on
with a small Force because he expected
to meet somebody on the other end of a
negotiating table that once he went in
and uh and that when that didn't happen
they did not have a large enough Force
to be able to mount an offensive and so
they've been building up that Force up
to now and they now have that force and
even against this all original Force the
ukrainians have been uh helpless
all of their offenses have died they've
now killed you know the head of the
Ukrainian um
Special Forces which was the probably
arguably by many accounts the best uh
Elite military unit in all of Europe
the the commandant the commander of of
the uh That Special Forces Group
uh gave a speech about uh four months
ago saying that 86 percent of his men
are dead or wounded and will cannot
return to the front he cannot rebuild
that for us
um the uh and you know the the the
troops that are now headed that are now
filling the gaps of all those 350 000
men who've been lost
are are scantily trained and they're
arriving green at the front any of them
do not want to be there many of them are
giving up and going over the Russian
side we've seen this again and again
again including platoon-sized groups
that are defecting to the Russians
and
um I don't think it's possible to win
and anybody you know I saw I I of course
I've studied World War II history
exhaustively I mean I saw a
um there's a new I think it's a Netflix
series of documentaries that I highly
recommend to people there it's they're
colorized versions of the black and
white
um
films from the battles of World War II
but it's all the battles of World War II
so I watched Stalingrad
the other night and uh you know the the
willingness of the Russians to um to
fight on against any kind of outs and to
make huge sacrifices
of the Russians themselves who were
making the sacrifice with their lives
the willingness of them to do that for
their motherland is almost inexhaustible
It is incomprehensible
to think that the uh that Ukraine can
can beat Russia in a war it would be
like Mexico beating the United States
it's just it's impossible to think that
it can happen and you know Russia has
deployed
a tiny tiny fraction of its military so
far and uh you know now it has China
with its mass production capacity
supporting its war effort it's just
it's a it's a hopeless situation and
we've been lied to you know we're the
the press in our country and our
government are just are just you know
promoting this lie that the ukrainians
are about to win and everything's going
great and that
Putin's on the run and there's all this
wishful thinking because of the the
Wagner group you know the uh the Goshen
and the Wagner group that this was an
internal coup and it showed dissent and
weakness of Putin and none of that is
true I was saying that that
Insurgency which wasn't even an
Insurgency he only got four thousand of
his of his men to follow him out of
twenty thousand
and they were quickly stopped and nobody
in the Russian military the oligarchy
the political system nobody supported it
you know and but we're being told oh
yeah it's the beginning of the end for
Putin
he's weakened his wounded he's on his
way out and all of these things are just
lies that we are being fed so they push
back on a small aspect of this he kind
of implied so I've traveled to Ukraine
and one thing that I should say similar
to the Battle of Stalingrad it is just
not is not only the Russians that fight
to the end I think ukrainians are very
yeah to fight to the end and the morale
there
is quite High I've talked to nobody this
was a year ago in August with her son
everybody was proud to fight and die for
their country and there's some aspect
where this war unified the people to get
gave them a reason and an understanding
that this is what it means to be
Ukrainian and I will fight to the death
I you know I would agree with that and I
I should have said that myself at the
beginning but you know that's the reason
my son went over there to fight because
the you know he was inspired by The
Valor of the Ukrainian people and the
you know this extraordinary willingness
of them and I think Putin thought it
would be much easier to sweep into
Ukraine and he found you know a stone
wall of ukrainians whether it read it
but they're
their lives and their bodies online but
that to me makes the the whole episode
even more tragic is that you know
um I don't believe I I and I I think
that the U.S role in this
um has been uh has you know that there
were there were many opportunities
to settled this war and the ukrainians
wanted a lot of marriage is a landscape
when he ran in 2019. here's a guy who's
a a comedian he's a he's an actor
um he had no political experience and
yet he won this election with 70 of the
vote why he went on a peace platform
anyone promising to sign the mystical
courts and yet something happened when
he got in there that made him suddenly
pivot and you know I think
it's a good guess what happened I think
he was you know he came under Threat by
Ultra natural and nationalists within
his own Administration
uh and the insistence of neocons like
Victoria new and the White House that
you know we don't want peace with Putin
we want a war
do you worry about nuclear war yeah I
worry about it it's uh it seems like a
silly question but it's not
it's a serious question well the reason
it's not you know the reason it it I
might it's not is just because people
seem to be in this kind of dream state
about that it'll never happen
and yet you know we're uh it can happen
very easily and it can happen at any
time and you know if we push the
Russians too far you know I I don't
doubt that Putin if he felt like his
regime was in or his Nation
was in danger that the United States was
going to be able to
place you know a quizling on you know in
into the Kremlin
um that he would use nuclear you know
torpedoes
um and uh you know these uh these
strategic weapons that they have and
that could be the man once you do that
nobody controls the trajectory by the
way
you know I have I have very strong
memories of the uh Cuban Missile Crisis
and of those 13 days
when we came closer to nuclear war you
know and particularly I think it was
when the U2 got shot down over
uh Cuba uh you know and nobody in this
guy there's a lot of people in
Washington DC who at that point thought
that they very male and may well may
wake up dead
that the world may end at night 30
million Americans killed 130 million
Russians
this is what our military brass wanted
they saw a war with Russia nuclear
exchange with Russia as not only
inevitable but also desirable because
they wanted to do it now
oh we still had a superiority can you
actually go through the feelings you've
had about the Cuban Missile Crisis like
what what are your memories of it what
are some interesting no in the middle I
was going to school in Washington DC to
um or to um
Our Lady of Victory which is in
Washington DC so we were I lived in
Virginia across Atomic and we would
cross the bridge every day into DC
and during the crisis uh U.S Marshals
came to my house
to take us I think around day eight
my father was spending the night at the
White House he wasn't coming home he was
staying with the XCOM committee and
sleeping there and they were up you know
24 hours they were debating and fake
trying to figure out what was happening
and
um but we had U.S Marshals come to our
house to take us down they were going to
take us down to um a White Sulfur
Springs
and uh in Southern Virginia in the in
the Blue Ridge Mountains where there was
a
um there was an underground city
essentially a bunker that was like a
city and apparently it had McDonald's in
it and a lot of other you know it had it
was a full City for the U.S government
and their families
U.S Marshals came to our house to take
us down there and I was very excited
about doing that and this was at a time
you know when we were doing the drills
we were doing the ducking cover drills
um once a week at our school
or they would tell you if they that you
know when the alarms go off
um then you you put your head onto the
table you take the remove the Sharps
from your desk
put them inside your desk you put your
head onto the table and you wait and the
ignition blast will take the windows out
of the school and then we all stand up
and and file in an orderly fashion into
the basement where we're going to be for
the next six or eight months or whatever
but in the basement where you know we we
win occasionally in those corridors
were lined with uh freeze-dried food
canisters off to this here from Florida
ceiling so people were you know we were
all preparing for this and it was you
know uh Bob McNamara who is my it was a
friend of mine and you know it was my
father one of my father's close friends
as Secretary of Defense
he later called Mass psychosis and my
father deeply regretted participating in
the bomb shelter program because he said
it was part of a a you know a
psychological psyop trick
to treat them to teach Americans that
nuclear war was acceptable
that it was survivable my father anyway
when they when the marshals came to our
house to take me and my brother Joe away
and we were the ones who are home at
that time yeah
um my father called and he talked to us
on the phone and he said
I don't want you going down there
because
um
because if you disappear from school
people are going to panic
and I need you to be a good soldier and
go to the school now and and he said
something to me during that period which
was that if the nuclear war happened it
would be better to be among the dead
than the living which I did not believe
okay I mean I I had already prepared
myself for the you know for the for the
dystopian future and I knew I could I
spent every day in the woods I knew that
I could survive by catching crawfish and
you know cooking Mud Puppies then we'll
do whatever I had to do but I felt like
okay I can I can handle this uh
and I really wanted to see the setup
down in you know this underground city
but anyway that was you know part of it
for
um me my father was away and you know
the last days of it
my father
um got this idea because Khrushchev had
sent two letters
he sent one letter that was conciliatory
and then he sent a letter that after his
Joint Chiefs and the warmongers around
him saw that letter and they disapproved
of it they sent another letter that was
extremely belligerent
and my father had the idea let's just
pretend we didn't get the second letter
and reply to the first one
and then he went down to dobrennan
and who was he met the Brennan in the
justice department and the Brennan was
the Soviet Ambassador and they you know
they proposed this settlement which was
a secret settlement
Eric Khrushchev would withdraw the
missiles from Cuba Khrushchev had put
them into Cuba because we had put
missiles you know nuclear missiles in in
turkey and
Italy and my uncle's secret deal was
that if he if Khrushchev removed the
missiles from Cuba within six months he
would get rid of the Jupiter missiles in
Turkey but if Khrushchev told anybody
about the deal it was off so if if news
got out about that secret deal it was
off that was the actual deal and
Khrushchev complied with it and then my
uncle complied with it how much of that
part of human history turned on the
decisions of one person
I think that's one of the you know
because that of course the perennial
question right but it is history kind of
on uh
an automatic pilot and you know uh human
decisions the decisions of leaders
really only have you know a marginal or
incremental bearing on what is going to
happen anyway but I think that is the
and historians argue about that all the
time
I think that that is a really good
example of a play a a place in human
history that uh literally the world
could have ended if
we had a different leader in the White
House and the reason for that is that
there were as I recall 64 gun
emplacements you know missile missile
emplacements
each one of those Muslim placements had
a crew of about 100 men
and they were Soviets
so on they were and they we didn't know
whether we had a couple of questions
that my uncle asked
Alan or ask the CIA and he asked Dulles
was already gone but he asked the CIA
and he asked um his military brass
because they all wanted to go in
everybody wanted to go ahead and my
uncle said my uncle asked to see the
aerial photos and he examined those
personally and that's why it's important
to have a leader in the White House who
can push back on on their bureaucracies
he
um and then he asked them
you know are those who's Manning those
missile sites and are they Russians and
if they're Russians and we bomb them
uh are they isn't it going to force
Khrushchev to then go into Berlin
and that would be the beginning of a
Cascade effect that would you know
highly like the nuclear confrontation
and the the uh the military perhaps said
to my uncle oh we don't think you'll
have uh you know we don't think he'll
have the uh the guts to do that so he
was my uncle was like that's what you're
betting on
and uh you know they all wanted him to
go in they wanted him to bomb the sides
and then invade Cuba and he said if we
bomb those sites we're going to be
killing Russians and it's going to force
it's going to provoke Russia into some
response and the obvious response is for
them to go into Berlin
oh the but the thing that we didn't know
then that we didn't find out until I
think uh you know there was a it was
like a 30-year anniversary of the Cuban
Missile Crisis in Havana
and what we learned then was that from
the Russians who came
to that event it was like a symposium
where everybody on both sides talked
about it and we learned a lot of stuff
and and never nobody knew before
one of the insane things the most insane
thing that we learned was that the the
weapons were already the nuclear
warheads were already in place they were
ready to fire
and that the authorization to fire
was made was delegated to each of the
gun gun crew commanders so there were 60
people
who at all had authorization of fire if
they felt themselves under attack
so you have to believe that at least one
of them would have launched and that
would have been the beginning of the end
and you know if they if anybody had
launched you know we knew what would
happen my uncle knew what would happen
because he asked again and again what's
going to happen and they said 30 million
Americans will be killed
but we will kill 130 million Russians so
we will win and that was a victory for
them
and my uncle said later said he told he
told Arthur Schlesinger and Kenny
O'Donnell he said those guys he called
them the salad brass the guys with all
of this stuff on their chest
and he said he said those guys they
don't care
because they know that if it happens
that they're going to be in the charge
of everything they're the ones who are
going to be running the world after that
so for them you know it was it was an
incentive to to kill 130 million
Russians and 30 million Americans but my
uncle he had this correspondence with
the Khrushchev they were secretly
corresponding with each other and that
is what saved the world is that they had
that both of them had been Men of War
Eisenhower famously said it will it will
not be a man of war
it will not be a soldier who starts
world war three because the guy who's
actually seen it knows how bad it is and
my uncle you know had been In the Heat
of the South Pacific
he's already been cut into by a Japanese
Destroyer
um his many three of his crewmen have
been killed one of them badly burned he
he pulled that guy with a lanyard in his
teeth
six miles to an island in the middle of
the night and then they hid out there
for 10 days you know and
um and you know he came back like I said
he was the only uh president of the
United States that are in the Purple
Heart
um meanwhile crew Chef had been a
Stalingrad which was the worst place to
be on the planet you know probably in
the 20th century other than you know and
Al Switzerland one of the death camps
it was uh you know it was it was the
most ferocious horrific war with people
starving people you know committing
cannibalism uh you know eating the dogs
the cats eating their shoe leather
we're easing to death by the thousands
Etc
a cruise ship did not the last thing he
wanted was a war and the last thing my
uncle wanted was a reward and they but
the CIA did not know anything about
Khrushchev and the reason for that
is the city there was a mole at Langley
so that every time the CIA got a spy
in the Kremlin he would immediately be
killed
so if they had no eyes in the Kremlin
you know there were literally hundreds
of Russia of Russian supplies Who had
who were who had affected the United
States and were in the Kremlin who were
killed during that period
they had no idea anything about
Khrushchev about how he saw the world
and they saw the Kremlin itself as a
monolith you know that it is uh
is kind of you know the same way that we
look at Putin today that you know it's
all they have this ambition of world
conquest and that's it's driving them
and there's nothing else they think
about they're absolutely single-minded
about it
but actually there was a big division
between Khrushchev and uh and his Joint
Chiefs and his intelligence apparatus
and they and they both at one point
discovered they were both in the same
situation they were
surrounded by spies and military
personnel who were intent on going to
war and they were the two guys resisting
it so when my uncle my uncle had this
idea of you know being the peace
president
from the beginning he told Ben Bradley
his one of his best friends who you know
was around the publisher of the
Washington Post
for the editor-in-chief at that time he
said um
Ben Bradley asked him what is what do
you want in your gravestone and my uncle
said he kept the peace
he said
the principal job of the president
United States is to keep the country out
of War
and um and
so when he first became president he he
actually agreed
to meet Khrushchev in Geneva to his
Summit and by the way Eisenhower had
wanted to do the same thing Eisenhower
wanted peace but his and he was going to
meet in Vienna
but that peace Summit was blown up he
was going to try to do
um
you know he was going to try to end the
Cold War Eisenhower was in the last year
of his of his in May of 1960.
but that was torpedoed by the CIA during
the U2 crash you know they sent you to
over the over the Soviet Union and it
got shot down and then they told and
then Alan told us
Eisenhower to deny that we hit a program
they didn't know that the Russians had
captured Gary Francis powers
and so when and and that blew up the
piece talks between Eisenhower and
Khrushchev and so you know they and
the uh there was a lot of tension
my uncle wanted to break that tension he
agreed to meet with
um
with Khrushchev in Vienna early on in
his term
he went over there and Khrushchev
snobbed him
khrushchev's lectured him imperiously
about the you know the
the terror of American imperialism and
and rebuff any you know they did agree
not to go into Laos they made an
agreement that kept the United States
became my uncle from sending troops to
Laos
but
um it had been a disaster Vienna so then
we had a spy that used to come to our
house all the time I cut Georgie
ballshank away he was this Russian
spy my my parents had met at the embassy
they had gone to a party or a reception
that Russian Embassy and he had
approached them and they knew he was he
was a GRU agent and KGB he was both
oh he used to come to our house they
really liked him he was very attractive
he was always laughing and joking he
would do rope climbing contests with my
father he would do push-up contests with
my father he was he could do the Russian
dancing the Cossack dancing
and he would do that for us and teach us
that and he was and we knew he was a spy
too and this was at the time of you know
the James Bond films were first coming
out so it was really exciting for us to
have a actual Russian spy in our house
the state department was horrified by it
but um but anyway
when Khrushchev after Vienna
and after
um you know the pigs
on Khrushchev had second thoughts
and he sent this long letter to my uncle
and he didn't want to go through his in
his State Department
or his Embassy he wanted to Enron them
and he was friends with
so he gave Georgie the letter and
Georgie brought it and handed it to
Pierre Salinger folded in the New York
Times
and he gave it to my uncle and it was
this beautiful letter which he said
you know
um he my uncle had talked to him about
the children who were played you know we
played 29 grandchildren who were playing
in his yard and he's saying what is our
moral basis for making a decision that
could kill these children so they'll
never write a poem they'll never
participate in election they'll never
run for office how can we make it how
can we can we morally make a decision
that is going to eliminate
life of these beautiful kids
and um he had said that to to Khrushchev
and Khrushchev wrote in this letter back
saying that he was now sitting as this
doctor
on the Black Sea and
um that he was thinking about what my
uncle jacket said to him at Vienna and
he regretted very deeply not having
taken the olive leaf
that jacket offered him and then he said
you know it occurs to me now that we're
all on an arc and that there is not
another one and that the entire fate of
the planet
and all of its creatures and all of the
children are dependent on the decisions
we make and you and I have a moral
obligation to go forward with each
other's friends
and immediately after that this was you
know he sent that right after the Berlin
crisis in 1962
General Curtis LeMay
um tried to
um had tried to provoke a war
with a an incident at Checkpoint Charlie
which was the the the entrance the
entrance exit through the Berlin Wall in
Berlin and the Russian tanks has come to
the wall the U.S tanks have gone to the
wall and there was a standoff
and my uncle had had uh sent a message
to Khrushchev then through dobren and
saying my back is at the wall I cannot I
have no place to back to please back off
and then we will back off and cruise
shaft took his word
hacked his Tanks off first and then my
uncle ordered lamaid back Ian Lemay had
mounted bulldozer plows on the on the
front of the tanks to to plow down the
Berlin wall and that and the Russian
sitcom so it was just you know it was
the right it was his generals trying to
provoke a war
and I'm
but they started talking to each other
and then when he after he wrote that
letter they agreed that they would
install a hotline
so they could talk to each other and
they wouldn't have to go through
intermediaries and so at Jack's house on
the cape
there was a red phone that we knew if we
picked up cruise ship wouldn't answer
and there was another one in the white
house yeah
and but they knew it was important to
talk to each other you know and you just
wish that we had that kind of leadership
today
I can I you know it just understands our
job
look I know you know a lot about AI
right and you know how dangerous it is
potentially to humanity and what
opportunity is at all so
um you know offers
but
it could kill us all I mean Elon said
first is going to steal our job and it's
going to kill us right yeah and it's
it's probably not hyperbole it's
actually you know if it follows the loss
of biological evolution which are just
the laws of mathematics that's probably
a good end point for it you know a a
potential endpoint
so
um we we need it's going to happen
but we need to make sure it's regulated
and it's regulated properly for safety
in every country and and that includes
Russia and China and Iran
right now we we should be putting all
the weapons of war aside and sitting
down with those guys and saying how are
we doing how are we going to do this
there's much more important things to do
we're gonna this stuff is gonna kill us
if we don't figure out how to regulate
it
and and Leadership needs to look down
the road at what what is the real risk
here and the real risk is that you know
AI will it will you know enslave us for
one thing
and you know and and then destroy us and
do all this other stuff and how about
biological weapons
we're now all working on these
biological weapons and we're doing
biological weapons from
Ebola and um and you know Dengue fever
and you know all of these other bad uh
things and we're making ethnic by
weapons bio weapons that can only kill
Russians
the Chinese are making that you know are
can kill people who don't who don't have
Chinese genes
so all of this isn't out within reach
we're actively doing it
and we need to stop it and we can easily
a biological weapons treaty is the
easiest thing in the world to do
we can verify it we can enforce it and
everybody wants to agree to it it only
insane people do not want to want to
continue this kind of research there's
no reason to do it so there's these
existential threats to all of humanity
now out there like Ai and biological
biological weapons we need to start stop
fighting each other
start competing on economic game fields
Playing Fields instead of military
playing fields
which will be good for all of humanity
and that we need to sit down with each
other
and negotiate reasonable treaties on how
we regulate Ai and biological weapons
and nobody's talking about this in this
political race right now nobody's
talking about it in a government
they get fixated on these little Wars
and you know and uh these comic book
depictions of good versus evil and you
know and we all go you know
and and go off to and give them the
weapons and enrich
you know the military
complex but we're we're on the Road to
Perdition if we don't end this and some
of this requires to have this kind of
phone that connects Khrushchev and John
F Kennedy that cuts through all the
bureaucracy to have this communication
between heads of state and in the in the
case of AI perhaps heads of tech
companies where you can just pick up the
phone and have a conversation because a
lot of it a lot of the existential
threats of artificial intelligence
perhaps even bio weapons is
unintentional it's not even uh strategic
it's actual effects so you have to be
transparent and honest about especially
with AI that people might not know
what what's the worst that's going to
happen once you release it out into the
wild and you have to have an honest kind
of communication about how to do it so
that companies are not terrified of
Regulation
uh overreach regulation and then
government is not terrified of tech
companies of uh manipulating them in
some director and direct ways so like
there's a trust that builds versus a
distrust
that that seems to so basically that old
phone or khushev can call
John F Kennedy is needed
yeah and you know I don't think there's
listen I don't understand AI okay I do
know I I can see from all this
technology how
it's this kind of turn keto
totalitarianism that once you put these
systems in place you know they can be
misused to enslave people and they can
be misused in wars and you know to
subjugate the kill to do all of these
bad things
and I don't think there's anybody on
Capitol Hill who understands this you
know we need to bring in the tech
community and say tell us what these
regulations need to look like you know
so that there can be freedom to innovate
so that we can
milk AI for all of the good things but
not you know fall into these traps that
are gonna you know that that are these
existential threats to that pose
existential threats to humanity
it seems like John F Kennedy is a
singular figure in that he was able to
have the humility to reach out to
Khrushchev
and also the uh the strength and
integrity to resist the uh what did you
call them the salad salad brass and
institutions like the CIA uh so that
that makes it particularly tragic that
he was killed uh to what degree was CIA
involved or the various bureaucracy
involved in his death
the evidence that the CIA was involved
in my
uncle's uh murder and that they can that
they were subsequently involved in the
cover-up and um and continue to be
involved in the car I mean there's still
5 000 documents that they won't release
you know 60 years later
um is I think so insurmountable and so
um you know a mountainous and
overwhelming that I it's beyond any
reasonable doubt
including you know dozens of confessions
of people who were involved in the
in the uh in the assassination but you
know all of every kind of document and
um and you know I mean it it came as a
surprise recently to most Americans I
think
um the release of these documents in
which the the Press
the American Media finally acknowledged
that yeah Lee Harvey Oswald was a CIA
asset and he was recruited you know in
nineteen
57 uh he was a marine uh working at the
attitude Air Force Base and which was
the CIA Air Force Base in you know where
the U2 flights which was a CIA program
and that
I he was recruited by James Jesus
Angleton who was the director of
counterintelligence
and then sent on a fake defection to
Russia and then brought back you know
um to to Dallas and people didn't know
that
even though it's been known for decades
it never percolated into the mainstream
media because they have such a
um you know they're they have such a an
allergy to anything that that uh that
challenges the Warren report
you know when Congress investigated my
uncle's murder
in the um in the uh in the 1970s
the church committee did and they did
you know two and a half year
investigation and they had many many
more documents and much more testimony
available to them uh than the Warren
Commission had and this was this was a
decade after the Warren Commission they
came to the conclusion that my uncle was
killed by a conspiracy
and there was a division where
essentially one guy on that committee
believed it was primarily the mafia
but Richard Schweitzer was the senator
head of the committee
um
said you know straight out the CIA was
involved in the murder of the president
United States
oh and and if I've talked to most of the
staff on that committee and they said
yeah I'm and the CIA was stonewalling us
the whole way through
and the actual people that the CIA
appointed George johannity's uh who
would who this CIA appointed as a
liaison to the committee they brought
him out of retirement he had been one of
the masterminds of the assassination
oh uh there's no
I mean it's impossible to even talk
about a tiny of the fraction of the
evidence here and what I I suggest to
people there are hundreds of books
written about this
that you know assemble this evidence and
mobilize the evidence the best book to
me for people to read um is James
Douglas's book which is called the
Unspeakable
and he Douglas does this extraordinary
as an extraordinary scholar and he does
this
it's an amazing job of digesting and
summarizing and mobilizing all of them
you know the probably a million
documents and you know the evidence from
all these confessions that have come out
into a coherent story
and it's riveting to read and you know I
recommend people who
do not take my word for it you know
um and don't take uh don't take anybody
else in word for go ahead and do the
research yourself and one way to do that
is probably the most efficient way is to
read Douglas's book because he has all
the references there so if it's true
that CIA had a hand in this
assassination how is it possible for
them to amass so much power how is it
possible for them to become corrupt and
is it individuals or is it the entire
institution no it's not the entire
institution my daughter-in-law
who's helping to run my campaign was a
CIA uh you know in the clandestine
services
for all her career she was a spy and
weapons of mass destruction program in
the Middle East and in China
and there's 22 000 people who work for
the CIA probably 20 000 of those are you
know our patriotic Americans and really
good public servants and they're doing
important work for our country
but the institution is corrupt and and
because the higher ranks the institution
and in fact Mike Pompeo said something
like this to me the other day he was the
director of the CIA said when I was
there I did not do a good job of
cleaning up that agency and he said the
entire upper bureaucracy
of that agency are people who do not
believe in the institutions of of
democracy
this is what he said to me so I don't
know if that's true but I know that you
know that's significant he's a smart
person and he ran the agency and he was
the Secretary of State
um but it's no mystery how that happened
we know the history the CIA was
originally first of all there was great
reluctance in 1947 that we had it for
the first time we had a secret
spy agency in this country during World
War II called the OSS
that was disbanded after the war because
Congress said
having a secret Supply agency is
incompatible
with a democracy Secrets by agencies are
things that like the KGB the stars in
East Germany Slovak and Iran and uh Peep
and Chile whatever you know all over the
world they're all have to do with
totalitarian governments
they're not something that you can have
that um it's it's antithetical democracy
to have that but
um in 1947 we created Truman signed it
in but it was initially
and it has to be an agency
which means information gathering which
is important it's to get to to gather
and consolidate information
many many different sources from all
over the world and then put those in
reports
of the White House or the president
um can make good decisions based upon
the valid information
evidence-based you know decision making
but Alan Dulles who was the you know
essentially the first head of the agency
made a series of
legislative machinations and political
imaginations they gave
additional powers to the agency and
opened up the uh what they called and
the plans division which is the plans
division is the dirty tricks it's the
Black Ops
fixing elections
um
murdering what they call Executive
action which means killing
foreign leaders
um and you know making small Wars and uh
and bribing and blackmailing
people stealing elections that kind of
thing and the reason at that time you
know we were in the middle of the Cold
War
and Truman and then Eisenhower did not
want to go to war they didn't want to
commit troops
and it seemed to them that you know this
was a way of kind of fighting the Cold
War secretly without and doing it at
minimal cost I um
uh by uh changing events sort of
invisibly
and so it was seductive to them but
everybody you know Congress when they
first voted in place Congress both
political parties said
if we create this thing it could turn
into a monster and it could undermine
our you know our values and today it's
so it's so powerful and that nobody
knows what its budget is
plus it has its own investment fund
which has invested you know made I think
2 000 investments in Silicon Valley
so it has ownership of a lot of these
tech companies that you know and the a
lot of the CEOs those tech companies if
not in state secrecy agreements with the
CIA which if they even reveal that they
have signed that they can go to jail for
20 years and have their assets removed
Etc
the influences the agency has the
capacity to influence events at every
level in our country
are is really uh frightening and then
for most of it's
um for most of its life the CIA was
banned from propagandizing Americans
but we learned that they were doing it
anyway so in 1973 during the church
committee hearings we learned
that the CIA had a program called
operation Mockingbird
where they had at least 400 members
leading members of the United States
press Corps
and the New York Times The Washington
Post ABC CBS NBC Etc
who were secretly working for the agency
and um and steering news coverage uh to
support CIA priorities
and they agreed at that time to disband
operation Mockingbird in 73. but there's
there's indications they didn't do that
and they still the CIA today is the
biggest funder of Journalism around the
world
the biggest funder is through usaid
I'm the USA the United States funds
journalism in almost every country in
the world you know it owns newspapers it
has journalists on thousands and
thousands of journalists on its payroll
they're not supposed to be doing that in
the United States but um you know in
President Obama changed the law to make
it legal now for the CIA to propagandize
Americans and I think you know we can't
look at the Ukraine war and how that was
you know has been how the narrative has
been formed in the in the minds of
Americans
and say that the CIA had nothing to do
with that what is the mechanism I wish
to say influences The Narrative do you
think it's indirectly through the Press
indirectly through the press or directly
by funding the Press directly through
I mean there's certain press organs that
have been linked you know to the agency
that the people who run those organs uh
things like The Daily Beast now rolling
stone you know editor of note Rolling
Stone Noah schlachmann
has deep relationships with the
intelligence Community uh salon
daily coasts
um but I wonder why they would do it so
from my perspective it just seems like
the job of a journalist is to have an
Integrity where your opinion cannot be
influenced or bought I agree with you
but I actually think that the entire
field of Journalism has uh
has uh you know really ashamed itself in
recent years because it's become you
know the the principal newspapers in
this country and the television station
the Legacy Media
have abandoned their
um
they're traditional their tradition of
of you know which was when I was a kid
listen my house was filled with the
greatest journalists alive at that time
people like Ben Bradley like Anthony
Lewis Mary mcgrory
Pete Hamill Jerry Jack Newfield uh Jimmy
Breslin
uh uh and many many others and after my
father after my father died they started
the RFK journalism Awards
to recognize integrity and courage you
know journalistic interior courage and
for that generation of Journalism
they they thought they believed that
that the function of journalists was to
maintain this posture of fierce
skepticism toward any aggregation of
power and including government Authority
that you always the people in Authority
lie and that way they always have to be
questioned and uh and that their job was
to speak truth power and to be Guardians
of the First Amendment right to to uh
free expression
but if you look what happened during the
pandemic
was the inverse of that kind of
Journalism where
the uh the major press organs in this
country
um were instead of speaking truth to
power they were doing the opposite they
were Broadcasting
propaganda they became propaganda organs
for the government agencies and they
were actually censoring um the speech of
anybody who descends of the powerless
oh and in fact it was it was an
organized conspiracy you know and it was
the name of it was The Trusted news
initiative and you know some of the
major press organs in our country signed
on to it and they agreed
not to print stories or facts that um
that departed from government Orthodoxy
so the Washington Post was the signature
of the UPI
the AP and then the um the four Media or
the four social media on groups
Microsoft Twitter
uh Facebook and Google all signed on to
the trusted news initiative it was
started by the BBC organized by them
and the purpose of it
was to make sure nobody could print
anything about government that departed
from government Orthodox is the way it
worked is the UPI and the AP and the
which are the news services that provide
most of the new you know news around the
country
and the Washington Post would decide
what news was permissible to print
and a lot of it was about covet but also
Hunter finds laptops where you it was
the impermissible to suggest that those
were real or that you know they had
stuff on there that was compromising
and um
and we you know and by the way
I this what I'm telling you is all well
documented and I'm litigating on it
right now so I'm part of a lawsuit
against the dni
and so I know a lot about what happened
and I have all this documented and
people can go to our website there's a
letter
on my substack now to um to Michael's
share of the Washington Post that
outlines all this and gives all my
sources
um because Michael Sheriff accused me of
being a conspiracy theorist when he was
actually part of a conspiracy a true
conspiracy
to suppress anybody
who is departing from government
orthodoxies by either censoring them
completely or labeling them conspiracy
theorists
I I mean you can understand the
intention
and the action the difference between as
we talked about you can understand the
intention of such a thing being good at
a time of a catastrophe the time of a
pandemic uh there's a lot of risk to
saying
untrue things but that's a slippery
slope that leads into yeah a place where
the journalistic Integrity that we
talked about is completely sacrificed
and then you can deviate from truth if
you read their internal memorandum
including the statements of the the
leader of the trusted news initiative I
think her name's Jessica uh Jennifer is
a Cecil
um and I you know you can go on our
website and see her say amen and she
said she says
the purpose of this is that we're now
she says when people look at us they
think we're competitors but we're not
the real competitors are coming from all
these alternative news sources now all
over the network uh and they're
hurting public trust in us and they're
hurting our economic model and we have
to they have to be choked off and
crushed and uh and the way that we're
going to do that is to
make an agreement with the social media
sites that if we say if we label their
information misinformation the social
media sites will um will de-platform it
or they will throttle it or they will uh
Shadow ban it
which destroys the economic model of
those alternative competitive sources of
information so that that's true but and
but the point you make is an important
point
um that the journalists themselves
who probably didn't know about the TNI
agreement certainly I'm sure they didn't
um they believe that they're doing the
right thing by suppressing information
that May challenge you know government
proclamations on covet
but I mean there's a danger to that and
the danger is that
you know once you appoint yourself an
Arbiter of what's true and what's not
true
uh then there's really no end to the
power that you have now assumed for
yourself because
and now your your job is no longer to
inform the public your job now is to
manipulate the public
and if you end up manipulating the
public in collusion with powerful
entities then you become the instrument
of authoritarian rule rather than the
you know the the opponent of it and it
becomes the inverse of Journalism and a
democracy
you're running for president as a
Democrat uh what do you are the
strongest values that represent the
left-wing politics uh of this country
I would say protection of the
environment and the commons you know the
air the water Wildlife Fisheries public
lands the you know those assets that
cannot be reduced to private property
ownership the the Landscapes are purple
mountain Majesty
the protection of the most vulnerable
people in our society people
um
which would include children
and minorities uh the restoration of the
middle class you know the and uh and
uh protection of Labor
dignity uh and you know decent pay for
labor
um
bodily autonomy a woman's right to
choose or an individual's right to
endure
unwanted medical procedures
um Peace
you know the Democrats have always been
any War
and that refusal to use fear is a
governing tool
of FDR said
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself because he recognized that uh
tyrants and dictators can use fear to
disable critical thinking and
um and
uh and overwhelm the desire for personal
Liberty
um the uh the the freedom of government
from untoward influenced by corrupt
corporate power
the the end of this
corrupt merger of the state and
corporate power that is now I think
dominating our democracy split
Eisenhower warned about
anyone against the emergence of the
military-industrial complex
and then I prefer to talk about the kind
of the positive vision of
what we should be doing in our country
and globally which is
you know I I see that the corporations
are commoditizing us are poisoning our
children or
um
strip mining the wealth from our middle
class and uh and treating
America as if it were business
liquidation converting assets to cash as
quickly as possible and you know and and
creating or exacerbating
this
um this huge disparity in wealth in our
country which is eliminating the middle
class
and creating you know kind of a Latin
American style feudal model there's a
these huge aggregations of wealths above
and widespread to spread poverty below
and that's a configuration that is too
unstable to support democracy
sustainably you know and we're supposed
to be modeling democracy but we're
losing it
um and I you know I think we have ought
to have a foreign policy
that restores our moral Authority around
the world or restores America
as the embodiment of moral Authority in
which it was when my uncle is president
and as a purveyor of Peace rather than
you know
or like Nation my uncle said he didn't
want people in Africa and Latin America
and Asia to think of when they think of
America to picture a man with a gun and
a bayonet he wanted them to think of a
Peace Corps volunteer
and he refused to send combat veterans
ComEd soldiers abroad he never sent a
single Soldier to his death abroad
um and uh and you know into combat
um he sent 16 000 he resisted in in
Berlin in 62. he resisted in Laos
uh in 61 he resisted
um
in in Vietnam you know Vietnam they
wanted him to put 250 000 troops he only
put 16 000 advisers which was fewer
fewer troops
and he's sent to get James Meredith into
the uh into the universe to Ole Miss in
Oxford Mississippi
one black man he sent 16 000 and a month
before he died he ordered them all home
he actually I think it was October 2nd
of 1963 he heard that a Green Beret had
died and he asked his aide for a combat
um list of Combat fatalities and the aid
came back and there was 75 men had died
in Vietnam at that point
and he said that's too Maddie we're
gonna have no more and he ordered he
signed a national security order 263.
and ordered all of those men all
Americans home from Vietnam by 1965 with
the first thousand coming on by December
63.
and then uh in November he of course
just before that evacuation began
he was killed and a week later on
President Johnson remanded that order
and then a year after that the Tonkin
Gulf resolution
we said 250 000 which is what they
wanted my uncle to do which he refused
and then and it became an American war
and then Nixon you know topped it off at
000 56 000 Americans never came home
including my cousin George skakel who
died at the Ted offensive
um and we killed a million Vietnamese
and we got nothing for it
so America should be the symbol of peace
and you know
today my uncle you know really focused
on putting America on the side of the
poor
instead of our tradition of you know of
of
uh fortifying oligarchies that were
anti-communism that was our you know our
major criteria if you said you were
against Communists and of course the
people were with the rich people or Aid
was going to the rich people in those
countries and they were going to the
military hunt us our weapons were going
to the hunters uh to fight against the
poor
and my uncle said no you know America
should be on the side of the poor and so
he launched the alliance for progress
and the usaid which were intended to
bring Aid to the poorest people in those
and build middle classes and uh and take
ourselves away in fact
his most his favorite trip his two
favorite trips while he was present
well his most favorite trip was to
Ireland
this is incredible
um emotional homecoming for all of the
people of Ireland
but his second favorite trip was when he
went to Columbia he went to Latin
America but Colombia was his favorite
country
and we I think what two million people
came into Bogota to see him this vast
crowd and they were just Delirious
cheering for him
and the president of Colombia
um said to him do you know why they love
you and my uncle said why and he said
because they think you've put America on
the side of the poor against the
oligarchs
and you know when my uncle after he died
today
there are more Avenues and boulevards
and hospitals and schools
named after and statues named after and
commemorating and Parks commemorating
John Kennedy in Africa and Latin America
than any other president in the United
States and probably more than all the
other presidents combined and it's
because you know he put America on the
side of the poor and that's what we
ought to be doing we ought to be
projecting economic power abroad
the Chinese have essentially stolen his
Playbook
and you know we've spent eight trillion
dollars on the Iraq War in its aftermath
of wars in Syria Yemen Libya you know
Afghanistan Pakistan
and uh what do we get for that we got
nothing for that money eight trillion
dollars
um we got we killed more Iraqis than
Saddam Hussein Iraq today is is a is a
worse much worse off than it was when
Sodom was there saying
it's an incoherent violent war between
Shia and Sunni death squads we pushed
Iraq into the Embrace of Iran it's now
become essentially a proxy for Iran
which is exactly the outcome that we
were trying to prevent for the past you
know 20 or 30 years
we created Isis we sent
two million uh refugees
into Europe
destabilizing all of the nations in
Europe for generations and we're now
seeing these riots
in uh in France and that's a direct
result from the uh Syrian war that we
created and and our creation of Isis
uh brexit is another you know result of
that so we for eight trillion dollars we
wreck the world and during that same
period that we spent 8.1 trillion
dollars
it's bombing Bridges ports schools
hospitals Etc the Chinese spent 8.1
trillion dollars building schools ports
hospitals Bridges and and uh and
universities
and now you know the Chinese are are out
competing us everywhere in the world
everybody wants to deal with the Chinese
because they you know they come in they
they build nice things for you and they
and there's no strings attached and
they're Pleasant to deal with and and
you know as a result of that
versus Hill is switching to the Chinese
currency
um uh Argentina is switching Saudi
Arabia our greatest partner that you
know we put trillions of dollars into
protecting our oil pipelines there and
now they they're saying
you know we we don't we don't care what
the United States think that's what my
mom and solemn said
he said we don't he you know they
he dropped
oil production in Saudi Arabia
in the middle of the U.S
um inflation spiral they've never done
that to us before to aggravate the
inflation spiral
and two weeks later and then they signed
a deal I mean a unilateral peace deal
with Iran which has been the enemy that
we've been telling them to you know to
be a bulwark against for 20 years
and two weeks after that he said we
don't care what the United States thinks
anymore so that's what we got for
spending all those trillions of dollars
there we got short-term friends
and the United States you know policy
abroad and we have not made ourselves
safer
we've made Americans we've put Americans
in more Jeopardy all over the world
you know you have to wait in lines to
get through the airport
um you have to
you know the security state is now
costing us 1.3 trillion dollars
and America is unsafer and poorer than
it's ever been so you know we're not
getting
we should be doing what President
Kennedy said we ought to do and what uh
what China the policy that China has now
adopted so that's a really eloquent and
clear and Powerful description of
the way you see us should be doing
geopolitics and the way you see U.S
should be taking care of the poor in
this country let me ask you a question
from Jordan Peterson that he asked uh
when I told him that I'm speaking with
you
given everything you've said when does
the left go too far
I suppose he's referring to
cultural issues
identity politics
well you know
Jordan trying to get me to bad mouth or
laugh the whole time I was in I really
enjoyed my my uh my talk with him yeah
he seemed to have that agenda where he
wanted me to you know say bad things
about the left and I just um you know
that's not what my campaign is about I
want to do the opposite
oh I'm not going to bad mouth laugh they
try you know I was on a show this week
with
David ramnick from the New Yorker and he
tried to get me to bad mouth Donald
Trump and you know and Alex Jones and a
lot of other people just and envating me
to do it
and of course there's a lot of bad
things I could say about all those
people but it doesn't you know I'm
trying to find
I'm trying to find values that hold us
together and we can share in common
rather than to focus constantly on these
disputes and these issues that drive us
apart so me sitting here bad-mouthing
the left or bad mouthing the right is
not going to advance the ball I I really
want to figure out ways that you know
what do these groups hold in common that
we can all
you know have a shared vision of what we
want this country to look like well
that's music to my ears but in that
spirit let me ask you a difficult
question then you wrote a book harshly
criticizing Anthony fauci let me ask you
the Steel Man the case for the people
who support him what is the biggest
positive thing you think Anthony fauci
did for the world what is good that he
has done for the world especially during
this pandemic you know I don't want to
sit here and speak uncharidly by saying
the guy I'm
didn't do anything but I I don't I can't
think of anything I mean if you
um if you tell me something that you
think he did you know maybe there was a
drug that got licensed while he was in
NIH that you know benefited people
that's certainly possible he was there
for 50 years
and I I in terms of his
um of his principal programs of the AIDS
programs and his covet programs and I
think that the harm that he did vastly
outweighed uh you know the the benefits
do you think he believes he's doing good
for the world I don't know what he
believes in fact
in that book which is I think 250 000
words
I never try to look inside of his head I
deal with facts I deal with science oh
and every every factual assertion in
that book is
cited and sores to government databases
or peer-reviewed Publications and uh and
I don't I try not to speculate about
things that I don't know about or I
can't prove and I do I cannot tell you
what his motivations were
or I mean all of us
he's done a thing a lot of things that I
think are really very very bad things
for Humanity a very uh deceptive
but we all have this on this capacity
for self-deception as I said at the
beginning of this podcast we we judge
ourselves on our intentions rather than
our actions and we all
have an almost infinite capacity to
convince ourselves
that what we're doing is is right and um
you know not everybody kind of lives and
examine life and it is examining their
motivations in the way that the world
might experience
um their professions of goodness
let me ask about the difficulty of the
job he had do you think it's possible to
do that kind of job well or is it also a
fundamental flaw of the job of being the
central centralized figure that's
supposed to know scientific policy no I
think he was a genuinely bad human being
and that there are many many good people
in that department over the years
um Bernice addy is a really good example
John Anthony Morris many people whose
careers he destroyed because they were
trying to tell the truth
one after the other the greatest
scientists in the history of NIH were
run out of that organization out of that
agency
um but you know I people
listening to this I you know probably
you know well in hearing me say that
will think that I'm bitter or that I
I'm doctrinaire about him but you know
you should really go and read my book
and I it's hard to summarize a
you know I try to be really methodical
to not call names to just say what
happened uh you are the bigger picture
of this is you're an outspoken critic of
uh pharmaceutical companies big Pharma
what is the biggest problem with big
Pharma and how can it be fixed
well the problem could be fixed with
regulation you know on the problems but
the pharmaceutical industry is
um
is uh I mean I don't want to say because
this is going to seem extreme that a
criminal Enterprise
but if you look at the history that is
applicable
um
descript or characterization for example
the four biggest vaccine makers
sanofi Merck Pfizer and glaxone four
companies that make all of the 72
vaccines that are now mandated for
America effectively mandated for
American children
collectively those companies have paid
35 billion dollars in criminal penalties
and damages in the last decade
and I think since 2000 about 79 billion
so these are the most corrupt companies
in the world
and the problem is that they're serial
felons
they you know they do this again and
again and again so
which
vioxidant you know they killed people by
falsifying science
and they did it they lied to the public
they said this is a headache medicine
and
um an arthritis painkiller
but they didn't tell people that it also
gave you heart attacks and they knew you
know we've found when we sue them on
their you know the memos from their Bean
counters saying we're going to kill this
many people but we're still going to
make money so they make those
calculations and those calculations are
made very very regularly
and then you know when they
um when they get caught they they pay a
penalty and I think they paid about
seven billion dollars
um for viox but then they went right
back that same year that they paid that
penalty
they went back into the same thing again
with Gardasil and with a whole lot of
other uh drugs so the way that the
system is set up the way that it sold to
actors the way that
um nobody ever goes to jail so there's
really no penalty that uh
It all becomes part of the cost of doing
business
and you know you can see other
businesses that if they're not if they
don't if there's no penalty if there's
no real I mean look
these are the companies that gave us the
opioid epidemic right so they knew what
was going to happen and we you know you
go and see there's a documentary I
forget what the name of it is but
it shows exactly what happened and you
know they corrupted FDA
they knew that this that oxycodone was
addictive they got FDA to tell doctors
that it wasn't addictive they pressured
FDA to lie and they got their way and
they've so far they left this year you
know those
they got a whole generation addicted
toxicodone and now you know when they
got caught and they made it we made it
harder to get oxycodone and now all
those addicted kids
are going event no and dying and this
year it killed 106 106 000. oh that's
twice as many people who were killed
during the Vietnam during the 20-year
Vietnam War but in one year twice as
many American Kids
and they knew it was going to happen
and they did it to make money so I don't
know what you call that other than
saying that's you know a criminal
Enterprise was it possible to have
within a capitalist system to produce
medication to produce drugs at scale in
a way that is not corrupt
yeah of course it is how through uh you
know through a solid regulatory regimen
you know where drugs are actually tested
you know I mean the problem is
not the capitalist system the capitalist
system I you know I have great
admiration for thinking that love for
the capitalist system is the greatest
economic engine ever devised
but it has to be harnessed to a social
purpose
otherwise it's gonna it leaves us you
know down
a trail of oligarchy environmental
destruction and you know and
commoditizing poisoning and uh and
killing human beings that's what it will
do and in the end
you need a regulatory structure
that is
um that is not
uh corrupted
I entanglements Financial entanglements
with the industry
and we've set this up the way that this
is that the system is set up today
has created this system of regulatory
capture on steroids
so almost 50 percent of fda's budget
comes from pharmaceutical companies
the people who work at FDA are you know
their money is coming their salaries are
coming from Pharma half their salaries
so they're you know they know who their
bosses are and that means getting those
drugs done getting them out the door and
approved as quickly as possible it's
called Fast Track approval and they pay
50 50 of fda's budget
it goes about 45 actually goes to Fast
Track approval do you think money can
buy Integrity oh yeah of course it can
and right right yeah I mean there's
that's not something that is that is
controversial of course it will so and
then controversial to me I would like to
think that scientists
I'm talking about population wide I'm
not talking about the individual but I'd
like to believe that scientists
I mean it in general career of a
scientist is not a very high paying job
I'd like to believe that people that go
into science that work at FDA they work
at NIH are doing it for a reason that's
not even correlated with money really
yeah
and I think probably that's why they go
in there but scientists are corruptable
and you know I the way
the way that I can tell you that is that
I've brought over 500 losses and almost
all of them involve scientific
controversies and there are scientists
on both sides in everyone
and when I said when we said Monsanto
there was uh on the Monsanto side there
was a Yale scientist a Stanford
scientist and a Harvard scientist and on
RSI there was a Yale Stanford and
Harvard scientists and they were saying
exactly the opposite things
in fact there's a word for those kind of
scientists who take money for their
opinion and the word is by astitutes
and they are very very common and you
know and I've been dealing them with
with them my whole career you know I
think it was Upton Sinclair who said
that it's very
um difficult to persuade a man of a fact
if the existence of that fact will
diminish his salary and I think that's
true for all of us if they you know we
find a way of reconciling ourselves
the things that are
the truth that actually and World Views
and actually benefit our our salaries
now NIH
um NIH has probably the worst system
which is that scientists who work for
NIH NIH itself which used to be the
premier gold standard scientific agency
in the world
everybody looked at NIH said today it's
just an incubator for pharmaceutical
drugs and and you know that is that
gravity of economic self-interest
because if you're
um if NIH itself collects uh royalties
they have margin rights for the patents
on all the drugs that they work on so
with the modern vaccine which they
promoted incessantly and aggressively
NIH on fifty percent of That vaccine is
making billions and billions of dollars
on it
and there are four at least four
scientists that we know of and probably
at least six
at NIH who themselves have margin rights
for those patents so if you are a
scientist who work at NIH you work on a
new drug
you then get margin rights and you're
entitled to royalties 150 000 a year
forever from that forever your children
your children's children as long as that
uh products on the market you can
collect royalties
so you have you know the Montana vaccine
is paying for the top people at NIH you
know some of the top Regulators is
paying for their boats it's paying for
their mortgages paying for their
children's education
and you know you have to expect
that the uh that in those kind of
situations the regulatory function would
be
um subsumed beneath the Mercantile
Ambitions of the agency itself and the
individuals who stand to profit
enormously from getting a drug to Market
those guys are paid
by us the taxpayer to find problems with
those drugs before they get to Market
but if you know that drug is going to
pay for your mortgage you may Overlook a
little problem and that we're even a
very big one
and that's the problem you've talked
about that the media Slanders You by
calling you an anti-vaxxer
and you've said that you're not
anti-vaccine you're pro-safe vaccine
difficult question can you name any
vaccines that you think are good
uh I think some of the live virus
vaccines are probably
uh so of earning more problems than
they're causing
there's no vaccine that is you know safe
and effective
the into big words
can we talk about well here's the
problem here's the problem
yeah here's the problem
the polio vaccine contained a
um a virus called semi virus 40 sv40
it's it's one of the most carcinogenic
materials that is known to man in fact
it's used Now by scientists around the
world to induce tumors and rats and
guinea pigs in labs
but it was in that vaccine 98 million
people who got that vaccine in my
generation got it and now you've had
this explosion
of soft tissue cancers in our generation
that kill many many many many many many
more people than polio ever did so if
you say to me the you know the polio
vaccine was effective against polio I'm
going to say yes if I say if you said to
me did it kill more people that it ever
caused more deaths than I've heard I I
would say I don't know because we don't
have the data on that
so but let's talk well you know so we
kind of have to narrow in on is it
effective against the thing it's
supposed to fight oh well a lot of them
are let me give you an example
the most popular vaccine in the world is
the dtp vaccine diphtheria tetanus and
pertussis it was used in this kind of
introduced in this country around 1980
That vaccine caused so many injuries the
Elias which was the manufacturer was
said to the Reagan Administration we are
now paying twenty dollars in Downstream
liabilities for every dollar that we're
making in profits and we are getting out
of the business unless you give us
permanent immunity from liability
so the vaccine companies and we're given
and and by the way Reagan said at that
time why don't you just make the vaccine
safe
and why is that because vaccines are
inherently unsafe they said unavoidably
unsafe you cannot make them safe
and so when Reagan wrote the Bill and
passed it the bill says and it's
Preamble is because vaccines are
unavoidably unsafe and the Bruce Woods
case which was the Supreme Court case
that uphold upheld that bill
uses that same language vaccines cannot
be made safe they're unavoidably unsafe
so this is what the law says now I just
want to finish this story because this
illustrates very well your your question
uh that the dtp vaccine was discontinued
in this country and it was discontinued
in Europe because that so many kids were
being injured by it
however The Who and Bill Gates gives it
to 161 million African children every
year
and
um Bill Gates went to the Danish
government
and asked them to support this program
saying we've saved 30 million kids from
dying from diphtheria tetanus and
pertussis
said can you show us the data and he
couldn't so the Danish government paid
for a big study
with Novo Nordisk which is a
Scandinavian vaccine company
in West Africa and they went to West
Africa and they looked at the DPP
vaccine for 30 years of data
and they they hire they retain the best
vaccine scientists in the world these
kind of deities of African vaccine
program Peter aab Sigrid Morganson and a
bunch of others
and they looked at 30 years of data for
the dtp vaccine and they came back
and they were shocked by what they found
they found the vaccine was preventing
kids from getting diphtheria tetanus
appetizers but the girls who got that
vaccine were ten times more likely to
die over the next six months than than
children who didn't
why is that and they weren't dying from
anything anybody ever associated with
the vaccine they were dying of anemia
heartsia malaria
sepsis
um and mainly pulmonary and respiratory
diseasement pneumonia
and it turns out that's what the the
um that this what the researchers found
who were all pro-vaccine by the way
they said that this vaccine is killing
more children
than diphtheria tetanus and pertussis
prior to the introduction of the vaccine
and for 30 years nobody ever noticed it
the vaccine was providing protection
against those Target illnesses but it
had ruined the children's immune systems
and they could not defend themselves
against random infections that were
harmless to most children but isn't that
nearly impossible to prove that link you
can't prove the link all you can do is
for any particular interest you can't
illness or after you can't prove the
link but you can show statistically that
there is that if you get that vaccine
you're more likely to die over the next
six months than if you don't and those
studies unfortunately are not done for
any other vaccines
so for every other medicine
in order to get approval from the FDA
you have to do a placebo-controlled
trial prior to licensure where you you
look at Health outcomes among a value
among an exposed group a group that gets
it and compare those to a similarly
situated group that gets a placebo
the only medical intervention that does
not
receive that does not undergo
placebo-controlled trials prior to
license or vaccines not one of the 72
vaccines that are now mandated for our
children have ever gone they're gone
a placebo-controlled trial prior to
licensor so I should say that there's a
bunch on that point I've heard from a
bunch of folks that disagree with you
including Polio I mean and the test
testing is a really important point
before licensure placebo-controlled
randomized trials
polio
uh received just that against the saline
Placebo control
so it seems unclear to I'm confused why
you say that that they don't go through
that process it seems like a lot a lot
of them do
yeah
here's the thing
is that
um I was saying that for many years
because we couldn't find any yeah
and then in 2016 in March I met
president Trump ordered Dr fauci to meet
with me and Dr fauci
and Francis Collins and I said to them
during that meeting
you have been saying that I'm not
telling the truth when I said not one of
these has undergone a prior pre-licenser
with Civic control
and Napoleon may have had one post
license like most of them haven't
the polio may have I don't know
but I said our question was prior to
license or do you ever test these
and for safety and by the way
I think the polio of vaccine
did undergo a saline Placebo trial
prior licensure but not for safety
only for efficacy
so I'm talking about safety trials now
I thought she told me that he was he
said I can't find one now he had a whole
tray of files there he said I can't find
that one now but I'll send you one I
said just for any vaccines send me one
for any of the 72 vaccines
he never did so we sued the HHS and
after a year of stonewalling us HHS came
back
and they gave us a letter saying we have
no pre-licensing safe dropped for any of
the 72 vaccines and that the letter from
HHS
which settled our lawsuit against them
because we had a foia lawsuit against
them is posted on chd's website so
anybody can go look at it so if CHD if
if
HHS had any study I assumed they would
have given it to us and they they can't
find one
well let me zoom out because a lot of
The Details Matter here pre-licensure
what does placebo-controlled mean so
this is uh
um this probably requires a a rigorous
analysis and actually at this point it
would be nice for me just to give this
shout out to
other people much smarter than me
that people should follow along with
Robert F Kennedy Jr use their mind learn
and think so one really awesome Creator
I really recommend him is Dr Dan Wilson
he hosts the debunk the funk podcast
uh vincerecan yellow who hosts this week
in virology brilliant guy I've had him
on the podcast somebody you've been
battling with is Paul offit interesting
Twitter interesting books people should
read and understand and read your books
as well and uh Eric topple has a good
Twitter and good books and even Peter
Hotes I'll ask you about him and people
should
as Paul outfit
published a sub stack recently debunking
I think my um
my a discussion with uh with Joe Rogan
and
um and we have published a debunk of his
debunking and you know let's hope you
read his stuff you should read both yes
you should read uh
and I would love to debate any of these
guys
uh so Joe Rogan proposed just such a
debate which is quite
fascinating to see how much attention
and how much funding it garnered uh the
debate between you and Peter Hotes why
do you think uh Peter rejected the offer
I think it's I think you know again I'm
not going to look into his head
but what I will say is if you're a
scientist and you're making public
recommendations based upon what you say
is evidence-based science you ought to
be able to defend that you ought to be
evident defended in a public forum and
you ought to be able to defended against
you know all comers
and you know uh so I I you know if
you're a scientist Science is based on
is rooted in logic and reason and if you
can't use logic and reason to defend
your position
and by the way
I know almost all of the studies you
know I've written books on men
we've made a big effort to assemble all
the studies on both sides
and so I'm prepared to talk about those
studies and I'm prepared to submit them
in advance you know and uh for each of
the points
and by the way I've done that with Peter
Hotes you know I've I've actually
because I had this um this kind of
informal debate with them
several years ago with them with a
referee at that time and we were
debating not only by phone but by email
and on those emails every point that he
would make I would cite science and he
could never come back with science he
could never come back with Publications
he would give Publications that had
nothing to do with for example if I'm
aerosol and vaccines Mercury based
vaccines he sent me one time
16 studies to to uh to rebut something
I'd said about thimerosal and not one of
those studies they were all about the
MMR vaccine which doesn't contain
thymaris also it wasn't like a real
debate where you're
you know you're you're using reason and
isolating points and having a you know
irrational discourse I I don't think
that he
I don't blame him for not debating me
because I don't think he has the the
science
are there aspects of uh all the work
you've done in vaccines all the advocacy
you've done that you found out that you
were not correct on that you were wrong
on it that you've changed your mind on
yeah there are many times over a time
that I
you know I found that I've made mistakes
and we correct those mistakes you know I
run a big organization and I do a lot of
tweets you know I'm very careful for
example my Instagram
I was taken down from for misinformation
but there was no misinformation on my
Instagram everything that I decided on
Instagram was cited or resourced to a
government database or to peer-reviewed
science
but for example the defender which was
our
um our organizations
uh newsletter we summarize scientific
reports all the time that's one of the
things the services that we provide so
we watched the you know PubMed and we
watched the peer-reviewed Publications
and we summarize them when they come out
we have made mistakes when we make
mistakes we are rigorous about
acknowledging it apologizing for it and
changing it that's what we do I think we
have one of the most robust fact
checking operations anywhere in
journalism today
we actually do real science and you know
there listen I've put up on my Twitter
account and I there's there's numerous
times that I've made mistakes on Twitter
and I apologize for it
and people say to me you know oh that's
weird I've never seen anybody apologize
on Twitter and I think it's really
important
at the only of course human beings make
mistakes my book is you know 230 or 40
50 000 words
there's gonna be a mistake in there but
you know what I say at the beginning of
the book if you see a mistake in here
please notify me I give a way that
people can notify me
and if somebody points out a mistake I'm
going to change it I'm not going to dig
my feet in and say you know I'm not
going to acknowledge this
so some of the things we've been talking
about you've you've been uh an outspoken
contrarian and some very controversial
topics
uh this has garnered
some Fame and recognition in part for
being attacked and standing strong
against those attacks if I may say for
being a martyr do you worry about the
this drug of martyrdom that might Cloud
your judgment first of all yeah I don't
consider myself a moderator and I've
never considered myself a victim I make
choices about my life and I you know and
I'm I'm content with those choices and
peaceful with them
I'm not trying to be a martyr or a hero
or anything else I'm doing what I think
is right because I want to be peaceful
inside of myself
um but I the only guard I have is just
is you know fact-based reality
if you show me a scientific study
that shows that I'm wrong for example if
you come back and say look Bobby
here's a polio
um here's a safety study on polio that
was done three licensure and used a real
saline solution I'm going to put that on
my Twitter and I'm going to say I was
wrong
there is one out there so you know but
that's all I can do
all right I have to ask you are in great
shape can you uh go through your diet
and exercise routine
my um
I do intermittent fasting so I eat
between I start at my first meal at
around noon
and then I try to stop eating at six
or seven
and then um I I I hike every day
morning evening in the morning
I go to a meeting first thing in the
morning 12's a meeting and then I go
hike hurt and I hiked uphill for a mile
and a half up in a mile half down with
my dogs and I do my meditations
and then I go to the gym and I go to the
gym for 35 minutes
I don't I do it short time I've been
exercising for 50 years
and what I found is it's sustainable if
you know if I do just the short periods
and I do four different routines at the
gym and I never relax at the gym I go in
there and I have a very intense exercise
and I live you know I mean I I could
tell you what my routine is but I do
I do backs one day back uh just one day
legs and then a miscellaneous and I do
12 my first set of everything is is I
try to I try to reach failure at 12 reps
and then my fourth set of everything is
a strip set
um I do I take a lot of um
vitamins I I can't even list them to you
here because I you know I I couldn't
even remember them all but I take a ton
of vitamins and nutrients
I'm on an anti-aging protocol from my
doctor
that includes uh uh
um testosterone replacement
and uh but I don't take any steroids I
don't take any anabolic steroids or
anything like that and the
DRT I use is Is bioidentical to what my
body produced what are your thoughts on
hormone therapy in general
I've talked to a lot of doctors about
that stuff you know because I'm
interested in health
and I you know I've heard really good
things about it but I don't know I'm
definitely not an expert on it
about God you wrote God talks to human
beings through many vectors wise people
organize religion the great books of
religions through ART music and poetry
but nowhere with such detail and Grace
and joy as through creation when we
destroy nature we diminish our capacity
to sense the Divine what is their
relationship and what is your
understanding of God who is God
well I mean God is
incomprehensible you know I mean I guess
the the most philosophers would say
we're in you know
we're inside the mind of God oh man so
it would be impossible for us Thunders
and you know what actually what you know
what God's form is or
um but I mean for me I have a
um
let's say this I had when I was
I was raised in a very very deeply
religious setting
so we went to a church in the summer
often times twice a day
good morning mass and we went to we
definitely went every Sunday and we um
and I went
we prayed in the morning we prayed
before and after every meal we prayed at
night we said a rosary sometimes three
rosaries a night
and my father read us the Bible
um when whenever he was home he would
read us you know we'd all get in the bed
and he'd read us the Bible stories
oh I and I went to Catholic schools I
went to Jesuit schools I went to the
nuns um and I went to a quaker school at
one point
when I I became a drug addict when I was
about 15 years old about a year after my
dad died and I was addicted to drugs for
14 years
during that time when you're an addict
you're living against conscience
and when you're living and I never you
know I was always trying to get off of
drugs never able to but I never felt
good about what I was doing
and um
and when you're living against
conscience you kind of push God to the
peripheries of your life so
I'll call me he
get receipts and get smaller
um and then when I
um
when I got sober
I knew that
I had a couple of experiences one is
that I had a friend of my brothers one
of my brothers who died of this disease
of addiction
I had a good friend who had used to take
drugs with us
and he became a Mooney so he he became a
follower of reverence young Moon
and he's at that point his compulsion he
had the same kind of compulsion that I
had and yet it was completely removed
from him
and so and he used to come and hang out
with us
but he would not want to take drugs even
if I was taken right in front of him he
was uh he was immune to it he'd become
impervious that I impulse
and um I when I was in the when I first
got sober I was I knew that I did not
want to be the kind of person who was
you know waking up every day in white
knuckling sobriety and just you know
trying to resist through willpower and
by the way
I had
um I had iron willpower as a kid I gave
up candy for Len when I was 12 and I
didn't need it again until I was in
college
I gave up um I gave up desserts the next
year for Lent and I didn't never eat
another dessert until I was in college
and I was trying to bulk up for a rugby
and for sports
so
um I felt like I could do anything with
my willpower but somehow
this particular thing you know the
addiction
was completely impervious to him and I
it was cunning bathing baffling
incomprehensible I could not understand
why I couldn't just say no and then
never do it again like I did with
everything else
um and um so I was living against
conscience and I and I I thought about
this guy
and I you know reflecting my own
prejudices at that time in my life I was
I said to myself I didn't want to be I
didn't want to be like a drug addict who
was wanting a drug all the time and just
not being able to do it
I wanted to completely realign my my
myself
so that I was somebody who got up every
day and just didn't want to take drugs
never thought of them you know I guess
the wife and children and went to work
and was never thought about drugs the
whole day
and I knew that people throughout
history had done that you know I read
the lives of the Saints I knew Saint
Augustine had had a very very dissolute
youth
and and you know I had the spiritual
realignment transformation I knew the
same thing had happened to Saint Paul
you know Damascus the same thing had
happened in Saint Francis Saint Francis
also had a
at a dissolute and fun loving Youth and
and had you know had this this deep
spiritual realignment and I I knew that
that happened to people throughout
history
and I thought that's what I needed you
know something like that
I had the example of this random mine
and I used to think about him and I
would think this again reflects the bias
and the you know
probably the meanness of myself at that
time but I said I'd rather be dead than
be a Mooney
but I wish I somehow could distill
that power that he got without becoming
a religious nuisance
and um and at that time I picked up a
book
um by Carl Jung called synchronicity and
Young
he was a psychiatrist his contemporary
of Freud's he was a I'm Freud was his
mentor and and Freud wanted him to be
his replacement but Freud was never out
atheists
and young was a deeply spiritual man he
had these very intense and genuine
spiritual experiences from when he was a
little boy from at least three years old
that he remembers biography is
fascinating about him because he
remembers him with such a detail
and um he uh
he was he had written he was always he
was interested in me because he was very
faithful scientists and I considered
myself a science-based person from when
I was little
and yet he had this spiritual Dimension
to him
which infused all of his thinking and
really I think made him you know it is
branded his his form of of recovery or
um of treatment
and he thought that this experiment
experience that he describes in this
book
where he's sitting up on the third and
one of the biggest sanitariums in Europe
in Zurich and he was sitting up on the
third floor of this building
and he's talking to a patient who had
who was talking describing her dream to
him
and the fulcrum of that dream was a
scarab beetle which was a insect that is
not is a very very uncommon if at all in
northern Europe but it's a
common figure in the iconography of of
Egypt and the hieroglyphics on the on
the walls of the pyramids Etc
and um
he and he while he was talking to her he
heard this bing bing bing on the window
behind him and he didn't want to turn
around to take his attention off her but
finally he does it he's in exasperation
he turns around he throws up the window
and a scarab beetle flies didn't lands
in his head and he shows it to the woman
and he says is this what you were
thinking of is this what you were
dreaming about and he he was struck by
that experience experience which was
similar to other experiences he's had
like that and that's what synchronicity
means it's a
it's a an incident a coincidence you
know and like if so if you're if you're
talking with somebody about somebody
that you haven't thought about in 20
years and that person calls on the phone
that's synchronicity oh and he believed
it was a way that God intervened in our
lives that broke all the all the rules
of nature that he had set up the rules
of physics the rules of mathematics or
you know to reach in and sort of tap us
on their shoulder and say I'm here
and um and so he tried to reproduce that
in a clinical setting
and he would put one guy in one room and
another guy in another room and have
them flip guards and then guess what the
other guy had flipped
and he believed that if he could beat
the laws of chance laws of mathematics
and he would have prove the existence of
a of an unnatural law a supernatural law
and that was the first step to proving
the existence of a god
he never succeeds in doing it but he
says in the book
um even though I can't prove using
empirical and scientific tools the
existence of a god
I can show through anecdotal evidence
having seen thousands of patients come
from this institution that people who
believe in God get better faster and
that the recovery is more enduring than
people who don't
and for me hearing that was more
impactful than if he had claimed that he
had proved the existence of a God
because I would not believe that
but I I was already at a mindset where I
would have done anything I could
to improve my chances of never having to
take drugs again by even one percent and
if believing in God
was gonna help me whether there's a God
up there or not believing in one itself
had the power to help me I was going to
do that so then the question is how do
you start believing in something that
you can't see or smell or hear or touch
or taste or acquire with your senses
and young provides the formula for that
and he says he says act as if he fake it
to you again
and so that's you know what I started
doing I just started pretending there
was a god watching me all the time and
kind of
life was a series of deaths and each
there was a bunch of moral decisions
that I had to make every day and each
one
you know these were all just little
things that I did but each one now for
me had a moral Dimension like when I um
you know when the alarm goes off do I
lay in bed for an extra 10 minutes with
my insulin thoughts or do I jump right
out of bed
do I how do I make my bed most important
decision of the day do I hang up the
towels you know do I um do I when I go
into the closet and pull out my blue
jeans and a bunch of those wire hangers
fall on the ground do I shut the door
and say I'm too much I'm too important
to do that that's somebody else's job or
not and so
I do I put the water in the ice tray
before I put in the freezer do I put the
shopping cart back in the you know place
and then it's supposed to go in the
parking lot of the Safeway
and if I make a whole bunch of those
choices right
that
um I maintain myself in a posture of
surrender which keeps me open to the
power of to my higher power my to my God
and when that when I do those things
right
um when I you know so much about
addiction is about abuse of power abuse
of
all of us have some power whether it's
our you know good looks or whether it's
uh
you know connections or education or or
family or whatever
and there's always attempts a temptation
to use those to fill fulfill self-will
and the challenge is how do you use
those always to serve instead God's will
and you know the good of our community
and that
to me is kind of the struggle and but
when I do that
I feel I feel God's power coming through
me and that I can do things I'm much
more effective as a human being
that that gnawing you know uh anxiety
that I lived with for so many years and
my God that I it's gone
and that um I can kind of like
put down the oars and always the sail
and you know and the wind takes me and I
can I can see the evidence of it in my
life
and you know the big thing for you know
the Temptation for me is that
um
when all these good things start
happening in my life and the cash and
prizes start flowing in
you know how do I maintain that posture
of surrender how do I Surrender then
when on my inclination is to say to God
thanks God I got it from here yeah and
drive the car off the cliff again and uh
so you know I had a spiritual awakening
and my desire for drugs and alcohol was
lifted miraculously
uh and it to me it was as much a miracle
as if I had if I'd been able to walk on
water because I had tried everything
earnestly sincerely and honestly for a
decade to try to stop and I could not do
it under my own power and then all of a
sudden it was lifted effortlessly and um
you know so I saw that evidence
early evidence of God in my life and I'm
of the power
and um and I see it now you know every
day of my life
so adding that moral Dimension to all of
your actions is how you were able to win
that kamu battle against the Absurd uh
it's all the same thing it's the battle
to just to do the right thing and now it
says if this was able to find somehow
happiness yeah
uh well Bobby thank you for the stroll
through some of the most important
moments in in recent human history and
for running for president and
um thank you for talking today thank you
Lex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Robert F Kennedy Jr to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
John F Kennedy let us not seek the
Republican answer or the Democratic
answer but the right answer let us not
seek to fix the blame for the past
instead let us accept our own
responsibility for the future
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time